president obama has been blamed for just
about everything even things that
happened five years before he was
president of the united states like when
spoke trump spokesperson Katrina Pierson
blamed Obama for the death of an army
captain in 2004 you might remember
President Obama became president in
January of 2009 President Obama has also
been blamed for the response to
Hurricane Katrina which also happened
when george w bush was president a 2013
poll actually found that almost 1/3 of
republicans blamed President Obama for
the bad response to Hurricane Katrina
which of course had nothing to do with
him he was not president at the time
he's been blamed for Ebola some aid
workers and nurses actually blamed Ebola
on President Obama the war in Ukraine
was blamed on President Obama it's a
very long list now and now a Republican
named Amy Holmes is actually blaming
Donald Trump on President Obama let's
see if we can figure out what case she's
making here and Amy the argument that
I'm making the political argument that
I'm making is that that's great for the
base that will put 20,000 people into an
arena all fired up but it doesn't win
general elections because there's just
not the cross-appeal that's necessary
how am I wrong I would agree with you
that no you can't win the presidency
with your base and that applies to the
left as well that applies to Hillary
Clinton but I disagree with your premise
that this is coming out of right-wing
radio my former boss Glenn Beck has been
on radio lambasted Donald Trump for the
last a year this is ridiculous if you
want to point a finger at who gave
Donald Trump you can point it to 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue and that is Barack
Obama that came from the midterm
election in 2010 that gave you the Tea
Party the midterm election in 2014 where
you had voters who said to Mitch
McConnell and Paul Ryan we want to put
the brakes on legislating by executive
action by President Obama taking this
agenda to the left and Donald Trump
supporters if you've looked at polling
data over the last year they actually
sort of span the ideological spectrum
not just from there right there also
from the center also disaffected voters
who want a voice in politics and they
feel that Beltway politicians have not
been listening to them for a very long
time but III think the argument is the
midterms saw the rise of the Tea Party
the Tea Party was against Obama using
executive action Trump supporters
include people from the Tea Party who
don't like the use of executive action
so thus Obama gave us Trump is that the
the story that Amy Holmes is telling us
here I think so but it's interesting
because the question also comes up is
this an attack on Obama's identity or
would she have applied this logic to
let's say Hillary Clinton if she had
been the president oh of course it's an
attack on Obama's identity yeah I mean
if look at if you look at the whole
executive action thing we've talked
before Louis about how President Obama
has actually used fewer executive
actions then certainly all Republican
presidents and and even fewer than some
recent Democratic presidents this is of
course what what she's really saying and
this is interesting because of I'm not
exactly sure what identity box is Amy
Holmes checks but shouldn't really
matter we're gonna analyze what she said
based on the words not on her skin color
of course this is about President Obama
as an individual who is half black and
is accused of being but Muslim by some
and whatever that's the anti sentiment
which has been coalesced by Donald Trump
yeah well what she did was she this is
this is kind of complicated but let me
let me go through this please so
Republicans over the past eight years
have blamed Obama for everything they've
been crafting this narrative that Obama
is to blame for XYZ race issues fiscal
issues poverty you name it
because they don't like Obama they don't
want him office and they wanted him out
four years ago and now what she's doing
is basically taking everything they said
claiming it's true and saying that this
is the reason that that we have Donald
Trump when in reality we have Donald
Trump because of the rhetoric that those
Republicans have been using for years
that's anti Obama and anti-immigrant and
anti-muslim it goes beyond that yeah I
mean the republican party has coddled in
incubated this horrifying authoritarian
nativist xenophobic homophobic
electorate while trying to sort of
publicly pretend that they're all about
a big tent and inclusion in whatever so
of course now Trump shows up and he's
way up front about the fact that he'll
build the wall and Mexicans are rapists
and Muslims are going to be banned and
the fact that the Republican Party has
sort of quietly sometimes not so quietly
actually allowed those ideas to exist
Trump puts them all together the only
the only people to blame are the
Republicans who have allowed this to be
a legitimate part of their party for the
last twenty years isn't it yes but she's
also not the first person who's tried to
blame Obama for Trump the former
Republican Louisiana Governor Bobby
Jindal said that it's funny already
yeah just his name just mentioning him
it's funny already it is in the Wall
Street Journal he said okay Obama
created Trump because he refused to work
with Republicans on health care reform
you know I remember it going a slightly
different way Jason I I thought it was
Republicans who were doing everything
possible to avoid any change to health
insurance into the United States yeah I
mean they're doing anything they can to
change not to change anything and to
keep you know all this money going
funneling into the pockets they want it
funneled into and they're definitely use
the same rhetoric you know once Hillary
is Hillary's elected they're gonna use
the same rhetoric for the next four
eight years to you know excuse you know
Trump losing and not getting their way
like much crybabies this is the second
time jason has used language that shows
it for him it's a foregone conclusion
that Hillary Clinton the the whole when
Hillary Clinton is president thing
you're I like how confident you are but
I'm not convinced yet I mean I'm an
optimist but there still are you know
what are 70 days left for everyone to
try to campaign and win so all right
well take a break back with more after
this